so my Secret's out I can finally be
honest with you I'm in the FNAF movie oh
and it's been a year and Not only was I
in the FNAF movie My Scene was the first
scene shot of the entire production day
one scene one I was there I also got to
meet Scott coffin after eight years of
us dancing around each other for the
first time in person but you know what
we're going to get to all that first and
most importantly I just need to
apologize I'm sorry that I had to lie to
you for the better part of the last year
to make it seem like I wasn't a part of
this whole thing I'm sorry that there
were so many of you that were convinced
that I wasn't in it and were mad at the
production on my behalf trust me I would
have been mad at the production too if I
had thought the same thing I never
wanted to cause any sort of stress or
anxiety or bad feelings to any one of
you out there and honestly for what it's
worth I cannot tell you how wonderful it
was for me to see so many of you up in
arms defending my right to be a part of
this thing I see each of you and I
appreciate what you guys were doing
seriously it meant the world to see so
many of you care and defend me like that
it was awesome I just hope that the
surprise of me walking out on stage and
being revealed to be in this thing was
worth all the fake out and let me be
clear at the end of the day no one from
the movie Once gave me any sort of
instructions on how to handle this whole
situation no one swore me to secrecy
there was no paperwork there were no
explicit instructions on what I couldn't
couldn't say it was all kind of implied
everything else was just kind of on me
but I also knew that if I didn't cover
the movie or do like live reactions to
the trailers on GT live things like that
that you all would probably figure it
out you would sense that something was
off about our content calendar that I
was hiding something from you and in
turn that would just ruin the production
secret and let me tell you I did not
expect them to make my life so
incredibly difficult especially when
they started throwing YouTuber cameos
into the trailers themselves thanks for
that one there guys is that doco no are
you kidding me we too are you kidding me
fun fact by the way they actually had me
read for that role literally a week
before their filming started so there I
was awkwardly in my basement at midnight
on a Friday with Steph filming me
reacting to a giant robot bear in the
imaginary back seat of my invisible taxi
cab no oh not cool man not cool oh and
also in case you are wondering actually
being in the movie kind of made making
theories predicting what was going to be
in the movie a bit tricky I had the
whole script and so basically unless
they rewrote the whole thing I knew
basically all the major story Beats kind
of felt like I would be cheating somehow
or spoiling the movie in advance
unfairly so instead that film Theory
prediction of the movie was one of the
few times where I actually took a
complete step back from the channel and
was almost entirely leaving the script
in someone else's hands letting film
theories creative director Lee handle
all the heavy lifting based on
information that was available via the
trailers and I got to say I was
surprised with just how much he got
right and also some of the things that
he missed but you know what that's a
theory for another day anyway so yeah
almost exactly one year ago all the way
back in November of 2022 I was contacted
by Blum House to be a part of the movie
or bad cupcake as they were calling it
back then it was the secret code name so
no one discovered what it was a week
before flying out they were still
shuffling me around to see what my part
would be and on February 1st day one
scene one I was in New Orleans to film
this thing hey there welcome to
sparkies okay but let's get real the
whole actor thing is kind of crazy
they're like no we will bring the stuff
to you and oh you can stay in your
trailer I'm like it's okay I can go get
my own food they're like no but you are
the actor one thing off the bat that I
didn't expect was actually the scale of
this thing because it was massive and
you're probably thinking well no dub
Matt it was a movie but I guess that
never really registered with me I mean
I've done professional theater before
I've done things like big Mr Beast
shoots where he takes over entire
football stadiums how different could
this actually be well it was different
it was huge I have never seen anything
this size before the number of people
the coordination I had a costume fitting
the day before and from my dinky little
Cameo of three lines in this movie I kid
you not they had me try on 20 different
combinations of outfits all of which had
to then be run by the director and Scott
for their approval I mean an entire
floor of a building was just full wall
toall of clothing hundreds and hundreds
of outfits Mike alone had practically an
entire wall all to himself it was
actually there that I got to see who
else was going to be a part of this
movie up on the wall that's where I
actually learned that Cory was going to
be a cab driver for the first time it
was also where I saw that good old
Markiplier was supposed to be the
security guard who gets killed at the
very beginning of the movie but probably
most importantly of all it's there that
I also saw the withered dabbing chica
posted on the wall like some sort of
guardian angel over the production
basically I was just doing the whole
theorist Thing by trying to pick up as
many small details and Easter eggs as I
could in what few moments I had left
unsupervised funny enough it turns out
the production staff were trying to do
the exact same thing right back at me
from the moment I stepped into my first
costume fitting people started to grill
kill me about FNAF it's no joke
apparently they had been briefed that I
was someone who had studied the
franchise a lot and so I was getting
inundated with all sorts of questions
about the type of person that Mike is or
how I saw William Aton in my mind's eye
or whether I could give him information
about characters like Abby I honestly
think it was them trying to get a feel
for whether they were on the right track
with all of this how the community as
fans might respond to all of this world
that they' created which honestly is
pretty cool the same thing happened the
next day when we were on location at the
shoot where all the other actors in my
scene between setups would take time to
ask me about how their characters
behaved in the games how their role fit
into The overarching Narrative of the
franchise but you got to say was kind of
a bummer because all the characters in
my scene were just made up for the movie
so didn't have a whole lot of detail to
impart on them so instead of all that
Heather Stewart Masterson uh she's Aunt
Jane in the movie she just ended up
asking me a lot of questions about the
parallels between Abby and baby from the
game since that's the one that her
character is probably most focused on in
general though it was clear that across
the board everyone was so eager to do
the franchise Justice they wanted to
know as much as they could they wanted
to learn they wanted to absorb all that
information and they were proud to be a
part of a project and being able to show
it off the only sad part of it all was
that I was so early in this process most
of the stuff wasn't even ready for me to
see yet they really wanted to show me
the pizzeria but schedule-wise the first
month of production was dedicated to
everything happening outside of the
pizzeria meaning that the set it was
still being built it was still in
process so when they took me to see it
it just got a lot of blank walls and
don't get me wrong they were impressive
blank walls very big very Majestic blank
walls but still left a lot to the
imagination same thing kind of happened
when they showed me the animatronics
everything was still locked away cuz it
needed final testing so the most I got
was like a little peek through a sliver
in the wall it's awesome think I could
make out the murder mask I'm like what's
up with that weird Freddy head and
they're like I don't know creative
decision but come to think of it it
actually kind of worked out really well
cuz when it came time to react to the
trailers when they were being uplo
uploaded to YouTube I didn't have to
fake anything cuz it was truly my first
time getting to see all of this thing
finished sure I knew the storyline of
the movie uh I had the whole script in
my hands and I knew what part I played
in this whole thing but seeing it all
actually getting to experience how it
all worked together it was my first time
no fake reactions here my friends and to
be honest seeing it on camera doesn't do
the scale of this whole thing Justice I
cannot stress to you how massive this
production was they literally built an
entire restaurant inside of an old
abandoned Home Depot in New Orleans
hallways rooms it was a complete
restaurant which was just mindblowing to
me most movies would probably tried to
do some clever camera tricks or green
screening or something but no they built
an entire building from the ground up
inside of another building crazy as far
as my role in all of this I had a
one-day shoot and that actual day I had
to wake up at 4:00 a.m. and then find a
car that had been left for me in a
random parking garage the night before
inside the car were explicit driving
instructions to a secret location really
felt like something straight out of a
spy movie from there I drove an hour out
of town to a random Diner that had been
shut down due to co once we were on
location they actually gave me my own
trailer they told me that's not the sort
of thing that a day player would
normally get but they wanted to give us
YouTubers the star treatment which I got
to say it was just like incredibly
generous of them that's right got three
lines baby that's what I get it's nice
where I'm going to be hanging out where
the next two episodes of Game Theory
going to be written probably inside my
trailer I found this this guy right here
little rubber chicken head little pencil
topper he was in one of the drawers and
so I I'm like you know what I'm going to
work him into my character and so if you
see him in the movie that's it little
Easter egg for you and from there it was
on to set where for the next 8 hours we
were working on a single scene that one
Diner scene you heard that right eight
straight hours one thing why so long
they had the cameras set up outside then
they had to move the cameras inside then
they had to have the specialty close-up
cameras then they had to remove half
half the booth to capture one side of a
conversation then remove the other half
of the booth replace the other half of
the booth to capture the other side of
the conversation then they had to remove
the booth entirely so they could put
cameras right here and capture a
close-up in my face there were b-rolls
of different tables getting served there
were b-rolls and Specialty shots of
dishes getting served up at the window
it was a lot for what ultimately amounts
in the movie to be like 3 minutes of
footage as you might imagine we all
started to get a bit creative with how
we were filling our time with each take
why what are you doing I'm filming this
for eventually I do the like hey I was
in this movie and it's behind the scenes
oh my goodness W so no pressure hey the
lengthy time between takes as they moved
cameras along also gave me plenty of
chances to explore the set for any hints
of lore and I actually found a lot of
really fun details buried in the walls
like uh here's one time where I found
the fake Diner registration information
here's another one where I found a QR
code that I was almost convinced was
trying to be a start of some new ARG
then I learned that it wasn't at which
point I decided to call that detail out
to the production team as being
anachronistic since this was meant to be
set at a time before QR codes became
mainstream and then they promptly took
it down so tldr of this entire video I
single-handedly saved the FNAF movie by
the way on the subject of small details
I don't know if you noticed it in the
movie but the diner I work in is called
Sparky Diner which is a reference to one
of the earliest urban legends from the
first FNAF game that there was this dog
animatronic named Sparky hidden
somewhere inside the movie is actually
full of these sorts of Easter eggs for
instance my character's official name
right here it's NES I don't know if you
noticed this one in the movie but it's
NES and I was told by everyone that
Scott specifically called out that he
needed me to be named NES at first I
immediately thought like oh this got to
be a reference to Ness from fnap AR or
maybe this is another instance of
Vanessa from security breach you know
just Scott trolling people by using the
same name over and over again but no
when I met him later in the day he told
me it was a reference to sans's n he was
very proud of himself speaking of the
man the myth the legend himself Scott
cin the whole time it was unclear
whether Scott would actually be there on
set it was one of those things that
people were like we don't know if
Scott's going to be there he might show
up we asked him if he's going to show up
on the first day I I thought that was a
little bit weird I mean it's your first
day of shooting your movie that's been
like five plus years in the making I
don't know you'd think that you try to
make an appearance there or something
right well he did but apparently was a
big surprise he flew in special for that
day it was interesting most of the
production crew didn't know who he was
they just knew him as the VIP on set who
everyone had to listen to if he asked
him to do something but no one actually
understood what he was that he was the
creator of the game I I think ultimately
it winds up being a movie thing you know
where he's just responsible for talking
to the director who's then the one who's
executing on his Creative Vision so a
lot of the rest of the day-to-day staff
don't really need to know that this is
the man that gave them a reason to be
there in the first place but yeah I got
to meet him it was great he has a good
strong handshake and he looks you in the
eye when you talk which is always the
sign of a upstanding person he was
wearing a classic Zelda t-shirt which
big props to that one and uh he was
doing a great job honestly of directing
everyone I overheard him Consulting some
of the costume department and clearly
outlining his vision of what everyone
should be wearing which was really cool
I think most people would probably have
been intimidated by this massive
production all leaning on him but it was
just really impressive to watch he made
sure that I knew about the whole Nest
joke and also about how he gave the
waiter roll bonus lines in fact he was
so proud of that one line that he asked
me to go over the top with it like I do
in the videos as part of the scene and I
did it for one take and it was weird
especially with everyone else in the
scene taking the scene so seriously and
so we all decided to keep it a bit more
toned down he took off before I left for
the day and I said I'll see you again at
the premiere and uh well there's no
Premiere so I guess that's the last time
ever going to see him oh and uh no to
answer your obvious question we did not
talk about lore we both swore that one
off instead we talked about the
community and how we both expected the
community to take this particular script
in the end he was just really grateful
for me being able to be a part of the
movie and that was mind-blowing to me
cuz I'm like are you kidding I was the
one who was lucky I got to be in this
mainstream movie how cool is that
growing up acting was one of my dreams
to be a performer that was always like
the end goal for me for for like the
first 18 years of my life and since then
that goals obviously changed a lot I've
moved on I've done something honestly
that I'm more proud of here where I'm
able to make a business and perform as
myself instead of as a character but
this was in a lot of ways a realization
of that dream that baby mat pet had
nearly a decade ago I actually recorded
a bit of my thoughts as I was getting
ready to leave the set it felt important
to document that's a wrap I was there I
was in it kind of sad but it was cool to
see a childhood dream in some ways get
realized it was kind of like I got a
peak into a Multiverse of another life
of mine and then that was it back home
like nothing had ever happened I did
keep the pencil topper and the name tag
as souvenirs though so uh yes I did
steal from the set of FNAF the movie uh
for two days this was just a small
window into something that was so big I
got to be a visitor in this massive
machine that I hopped off of and then
that just continued on without me but
man let me tell you it is surreal to see
posters going up in theaters of a movie
that you're in oh can I can I level with
you for a second this whole thing it was
so intimidating you know how I keep
doing videos this year about being in
the PGA Tour or producing a Broadway
show and how the theme of the Year
happens to be like say yes and to your
life well this was actually the first of
those things cuz it was at the top of
the Year this was the thing that got me
started on the whole theme because it is
one thing to speak as yourself on a
couch about things that you know and it
is something entirely different to walk
in as a complete Noob and say scripted
lines as a random character named after
a meme to a crew of seasoned actors
while they're stopping public traffic
outside and 50 production staff are
slowly zooming a camera into your face I
mean I've done a lot of performances but
this this was just at another level the
only thing that I asked the director
Emma to make sure of was that I didn't
deliver some sort ort of like cringy
YouTuber performance you know what I
mean it can't not be cringey when you're
saying your like own catchphrase that's
kind of silly but you know I just I
didn't want to bring the movie down and
to be honest I I think I did all right
anyway that right there my friends that
is my story and it feels so good so good
to finally come clean about it I have
wanted to bring you in as a part of this
journey for the longest time in the end
I just I cannot thank the team there
enough for all their incredible
generosity and their patience and Scott
thank you for giving me me the chance to
be a part of this but most importantly
thank you this whole thing this is our
Collective Victory right because without
you supporting me or supporting these
channels and supporting these wacky
theories none of this would have been
possible and if you haven't seen the
movie then what the heck are you waiting
for watch it and then go watch it again
show them the force of Team Internet so
that the late night hosts and the
executive producers finally learn that
things from the internet deserve to be
pronounced correctly anyway in the end
who knows maybe there'll be room in the
sequel for the return of a well-meaning
cringy waiter with a love of breakfast
and a mish name but until then remember
that's not a theory it's just a video
video for you thanks for
watching